zone europe
bonjour et bienvenue dans une europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de bruxelles est
réalisée en association avec tv 78
heureux de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle saison voici le sommaire de ce
nouveau numéro 20 ans après avoir été
chassé du pouvoir les talibans ont
repris le contrôle de l'afghanistan quel
avenir pour les femmes dans ces
conditions je recevrai l'eurodéputé
belge assite à cancon l'histoire de
l'europe nous allons vous raconter le
parcours de simone veil elle a été la
première femme présidente du parlement
européen de 1979 à 1982
les expressions populaires jamais les
français disent quand les poules auront
des dents que dit-on ailleurs c'est ce
que nous verrons à la fin de cette
émission mais avant que fait l'europe
dans notre région un exemple tout de
suite
zone robe l'europe dans ma région
avec toujours plus de nouvelles
technologies la fraude est de moins en
moins rare au total en 2020 le montant
de la fraude bancaire en france a
atteint 5 525 millions d'euros pour
parler aujourd'hui je suis avec france a
souligné le ceo de la société blackwell
bonjour bonjour alors blake wood est née
au sein de l'entreprise de cybersécurité
r comme et développe des solutions
d'analysé comportementale pour lutter
contre la fraude dans le paiement en
quoi une société comme la vôtre est
important de nos jours à notre époque
c'est une société qui est évidemment une
mission sociale très très importante
parce que on a pour ambition de limiter
les impacts des activités criminelles et
il écrivait dans le monde de la finance
pour rendre la société meilleur tout
simplement alors pour prévenir et
détecter la fraude vous reposer sur deux
choses le machine learning et donc
l'intelligence artificielle donc ces
deux choses dit en une seule d'après ce
que j'ai compris on reviendrait plus
tard sur tout ça avec des mots simples
qu'est ce que le machine learning le
machine learning c'est une méthodologie
de l'analyse et qui statistiques qui va
s'appuyer sur l'ensemble des
informations qu'on va pouvoir collecter
des des montants des destinations de
pays sur les virements etc on va faire
une analyse statistique et on va
construire un modèle un modèle
mathématique
en s'appuyant évidemment sur des
algorithmes et de ses analyses
statistiques vont sortir une prédiction
en termes de risques de fraude et quel
est le rapport justement entre machine
learning et intelligence artificielle
alors l'intelligence artificielle c'est
le non plus plus large un domaine un
domaine particulier de l'informatique et
le machine leur nid est un des 1 1 une
technique un sous-ensemble des
différentes techniques qui existent dans
le monde de l'intelligence artificielle
donc on va retrouver le machine learning
ledit planning les systèmes experts etc
etc et en cause justement ces principes
de machine learning intelligence
artificielle ça vous aide dans votre
dans vos missions alors ça nous aide
parce que de manière traditionnelle dans
ses systèmes antifraude on utilise des
modèles plutôt basée sur des règles
métiers exprimées par des des humains et
l'analyse statistique l'entraînement
automatisé en fait va permettre de
s'abstraire de tous les biais cognitifs
qu'on peut avoir quand on est en train
de de décrire un modèle de manière
manuelle alors là plusieurs pour grandes
banques françaises qui vous font
également confiance mais à part ça qui
s'adressent vos services concrètement
alors no service s'adresse aux banques
évidemment et à toutes les institutions
financières et les finitec notamment
qu'on va pouvoir retrouver partout dans
le monde donc les fintec du paiement les
films tech du virement du transfert de
devises à les organismes de crédit donc
voilà on a un panel assez large de
clients potentiels c'est facile de vous
faire confiance à une entreprise comme
la vôtre justement quand on parle de
machine learning intelligence
artificielle s'est pas trop puisque
c'est au final est-ce que les gens vous
font confiance alors oui les gens nous
font confiance à puisqu'un pierre
cliente d'une part mais c'est surtout on
a à coeur de démystifier auprès de nos
clients un petit peu ce qu'on met en
place parce que représente
l'intelligence artificielle et même dans
le service qu'on rend en fait on se
contente pas de détecter la fraude mais
aussi de donner une explication une
contextualisation pour que les
utilisateurs nos utilisateurs puissent
comprendre les raisons pour lesquelles
on pense que la transaction est
suspicieuse vous travaillé notamment
avec carrefour banque et assurance en
six mois de collaboration seulement vous
leur avait permis d'éviter un 8 millions
d'euros de fraudes qu'est ce que vous
ressentez quand vous voyez des résultats
pour votre entreprise de tels résultats
avant tout une grande fierté qu'ont fait
correctement notre travail que notre
action a un impact réel sur sur chercher
chez nos clients et puis une grande
fierté pas que pour l'entreprise mais
aussi pour toute l'équipe mary qui est
impliqué qui travaillent quotidiennement
pour améliorer ses maîtres mettre en
place ses modèles mais également
améliorer ses modèles améliorer le
service rendu aux clients et en 2019
j'ai cru comprendre que votre art of
votre start-up pardon a réalisé une
levée de fonds de 2 9 millions d'euros
en quoi ça aide une levée de fonds de
telle sorte comme ça alors cette cette
levée de fonds elle nous a aidé à
construire une équipe donc à recruter un
certain nombre de personnes à la fois
des profils dans la recherche et
développement que six profils
commerciaux pour assurer le
développement de l'entreprise donc les
ces fonds là sont là pour vraiment aider
au développement à structuration
d'entreprise pour aller décrocher des
nouveaux clients et s'assurer que
l'entreprise est sur les rails sur les
rails de la croissance dit avec des mots
assez simple comment on fait pour éviter
une fraude dans une banque imaginant
comment on fait pour prévenir de tout ça
pour éviter une fraude dans le doute
dans une banque en tant que particulier
voulait dire en tant que particulier ou
en tant que professionnel comme vous
alors entendre particulier les choses
ultra importante est aujourd'hui à
beaucoup beaucoup d' attaques sur
internet donc c'est s'assurer que les
données confidentielles reste bien
protégé ne pas les divulguer éviter de
transmettre ses informations données
personnelles dans mails ou sur les
réseaux sociaux etc et puis pour pour
nous comment comment on met en place ces
systèmes là on va s'appuyer sur des
historiques l'historique de données de
nos clients qui ont observé toute
l'ordre il ya deux ans d'historique de
transactions de paiement et on va
s'appuyer sur les informations qui vous
collectez en termes de fraude dans le
passé et donc c'est à partir de ces
informations pas c'est qu'on va pouvoir
venir faire une prédiction parce qu'on a
observé des comportements des patterns
comportementaux donc des observations
comportementales de des clients du passé
des fraudeurs du passé pour venir
prédire les fraudes du futur la fraude
c'est quelque chose qui est fréquent
dans une banque par exemple ou dans des
centres des grandes entreprises de
finances
fréquent alors ça va dépendre du secteur
d'activité mais c'est quelque chose qui
est qui qui est de plus en plus
fréquents et avec la crise sanitaire qui
s'est présentée et notamment le fait que
les gens soit la distance et utilise des
plateformes dématérialisées
on a vu une augmentation significative
des fraudes notamment en lien avec la
fausse identité ou d'usurpation
d'identité la crise sanitaire a été
vraiment un catalyseur catalyseur on a
tous à wes a vraiment amené une
accélération des délais fraude dans le
secteur bancaire alors on a parlé tout à
l'heure de votre levée de fonds de 9
millions d'euros donc c'était un an
après que blekko n ai pris son
indépendance ça vous fait quoi de voir
que des entreprises des fonds ou font
confiance à ce moment là
sur un plan personnel c'est évidemment
satisfaisant ah mais c'est aussi le
fruit d'un travail d'un travail
personnel d'un travail collectif du
travail de toute une équipe
du coup on est forcément
fière et quelque peu angoissé parce que
on sent investi d'une grande
responsabilité une responsabilité
vis-à-vis de la mission sociale que peut
avoir de l'écho m et puis aussi les
fonds qu on nous a confié on a envie de
faire quelque chose d'utile pour la
société tout simplement alors pendant
qu'on parle de financement vous avez pu
bénéficier aussi des de l'europe à
combien s'élevait cette aide et qu'est
ce qu'elle a pu vous permettre de faire
c'est un financement de 2 de l'europe
cofinancer que la région en fonds feder
de l'ordre d'un million d'euros et se
font là nous a servi au tout début de
l'aventuré de blake wayne sur les
travaux de prototypes talent prototypage
de la solution justement pour nous
permettre d'aller démarcher par la suite
les prospects que sont comme vous
l'étiez bnp carrefour banque ou encore
il faut aujourd'hui en angleterre
comment est née blackwell comment est
née blackwell blake wayne c'est le
rennais au sein de d'ercom et c'est un
projet intrapreneur yann donc avec un
collègue à droite françois un autre
françois françois d'opinion et on a
monté cette structure et quand
thales a racheté r comme nos
actionnaires historiques ont décidé de
de nous qui nous fait comme on dit dans
le jargon des start up pour nous donner
notre indépendance et notre notre
autonomie part pour pouvoir développer
cette structure les avais cause
justement de voir qu'une entreprise
comme air comme vous prend la décision
de vous donner votre indépendance trimer
votre mission propre à vous
en on se dit que l'on n'a pas si mal
bossé que ça tout simplement alors on a
parlé tout à l'heure de comment éviter
les fraudes fiscales etc mais comment
les prévenir comment anticiper tout ça
comment anticiper les fraudes alors on
va mettre en place au plus de plus en
plus de contrôler en fait il valoir est
âgée un certain nombre de contrôles si
je vais prendre l'exemple du crédit dont
la détection de fraude à l'octroi de
crédits on
nous on intervient enfin d'octroi de
crédit on a tous tes données consolidées
et on va donner un risque de fraude sur
le dossier mais à l'entrée en relation
on va déjà établi un certain nombre de
contrôles il avait dû des clients ce qui
s'appelle le quesnoy ici le new york à
sa main en anglais
et on va venir établir aussi son profil
pour s'assurer que ce n'est pas une
fausse identité que ce n'est pas une
usurpation d'identité
que la personne a un projet réel dont
l'intention n'est pas de d'acheter des
armes de la drogue avec etc on va voir
un certain nombre d'outils qui vont
venir complémenter ou qui vont s'agréger
ensemble pour mettre en place sa
détection de fonte vous avez parlé de
contrôler les identités et sait comment
vous y prenez pour que ça alors nous on
fait pas du contrôle d'identité doivent
contrôler la cohérence de l'ensemble des
informations des clients qu'on va
observer en revanche il ya des solutions
spécialisées qui vont se concentrer
exclusivement sur
vérifier lit dans la validité d'une
pièce d'identité d'un d'un client
potentiel désormais on en sait un peu
plus sur blake wood merci beaucoup
françois d'avoir participé à cette
émission nous rappelle que vous êtes le
ceo de cette start up on s'intéresse à
présent à l'histoire de l'europe simone
veil a été la première femme présidente
du parlement européen de 1979 à 1982
son parcours avec la maison de l'europe
et europe direct
soon europe
simone veil de son nom de jeune fille
simone haan jacob est née le 13 juillet
1927 à nice issu d'une famille juive
elle est déportée en mars 1944 alors
qu'elle n'a que 16 ans elle vit pendant
13 mois les atrocités de la seconde
guerre mondiale et les camps de
concentration malgré ces épreuves simone
veil reprend ses études de droit et
entre dans la magistrature en 1957 en
1970 elle est la première femme à
occuper le poste de secrétaire général
du conseil supérieur de la magistrature
après avoir été haut fonctionnaire de
l'administration pénitentiaire du
ministère de la justice
son expérience et ses prises de
positions l'amène à être nommé ministre
de la santé sous valéry giscard
d'estaing et dans le gouvernement de
chirac en mai 1974 elle propose au
parlement un projet de loi pour
dépénaliser l'avortement ses prises de
position sur le sujet sont devenus
célèbres et en janvier 1975 l'avortement
est légalisé en france
en 1979 elle participe aux premières
élections européennes sur la liste de
l'union pour la démocratie française
elle est élue membre du parlement
européen et elle en devient la
présidente est la première femme à
occuper ce poste son élection au
parlement européen est un symbole fort
symbole de la réconciliation franco
allemande simone veil considère le
projet européen comme un moyen de
maintenir la paix et de tourner la page
des guerres mondiales
lors de son discours d'investiture à la
présidence du parlement européen elle
énonce ses trois ambitions pour l'europe
pour relever les défis auxquels l'europe
est confrontée c'est dans trois
directions qu'il nous faudra l'orienter
l'europe de la solidarité l'europe de
l'indépendance l'europe de la
coopération elle contribue à donner une
place politique réelle au parlement
européen dans la prise de décision elle
est récompensée en 1981 du prix
charlemagne qui récompense des
personnalités qui ont oeuvré pour la
construction européenne elle quitte le
parlement européen en 1993 et rejoint le
gouvernement français comme ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé et de
la vie elle est par la suite membre du
conseil constitutionnel dur en avant au
niveau européen elle est de nouveau
sollicité en 1996 pour être membre de la
commission internationale pour les
balkans son dernier engagement politique
pour l'europe intervient lors de la
campagne pour la ratification par la
france du traité constitutionnel
européen de 2005
elle soutient le oui au référendum avec
énergie simone veil a également occupé
la place de présidente de la shoah
memory foundation et a été membre du
conseil d'administration de l'ifri en
2008 elle est élue à l'académie
française
son travail pour l'europe a été reconnue
en france et à l'étranger et on retient
d'elle une vision d'espoir et de progrès
pour l'europe simone veil est décédé en
2010 est à l'âge de 89 ans et est entré
au panthéon en 2018
zone europe l'invité politique
le 15 août dernier en seulement quelques
heures kaboul tombée aux mains des
talibans 20 ans après avoir été chassé
du pouvoir les talibans ont repris le
contrôle de l'afghanistan
quel avenir pour les femmes dans ces
conditions aujourd'hui je reçois
l'eurodéputé belge à sita coco bonjour
brunch ou alors vous êtes membre de la
commission des libertés civiles de la
justice et des affaires intérieures et
membre de la sous-commission des droits
de l'homme tout d'abord votre sentiment
sur cette prise de pouvoir des talibans
l'afghanistan c'était un combat
peut-être déjà perdu d'avancé pour les
forces internationales dès leur arrivée
je ne crois pas que c'était un combat
perdu d'avancé
mais aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte
qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'erreurs et quand
on regarde la façon dont l'ancien
président donc fin le président afghan
s'est enfui en abandonnant son pays et
son peuple ensemble et apparemment avec
beaucoup d'argent on se rend compte que
la communauté internationale a beaucoup
sponsoriser la corruption qu'il n'y a
pas eu qu'ils aient eu beaucoup
d'assistanat et qu'il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de renforcement de la capacité
au niveau local donc je dis moi je suis
très inquiète pour la situation des
femmes et des filles mais une fois de
plus on peut je voudrais parler d'une
phrase qu'a dit une journaliste de cnn
et madame ward qui a dit que quand il ya
eu les attentats du 11 septembre elle
était assise quelque part et elle se dit
j'ai honte je n'ai pas fait attention à
ce qui se passait dans le monde j'ai
l'impression que tous les jours on
répète la même aujourd'hui on apprend de
parler de l'afghanistan
on a oublié ce qui s'est passé les
années écoulées
mais est ce qu on se rend bien compte de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
pas seulement à nathalie st moïse mais
aussi ailleurs pour les mêmes raisons et
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'un échec
militaire mais surtout d'un échec
politique finalement c'est un échec
stratégique c'est un échec au niveau de
tout ce qui est politique internationale
et diplomatie ça devrait vraiment rentré
dans les cas d'école pour les tous les
étudiants en sciences politiques ou aux
diplomaties je pense que on persiste
également dans l'erreur est le dindon de
la farce un peu c'est l'union européenne
qui n'a même pas réussi à trouver sa
place dans cette conversation dans ce
dialogue alors que là il y aura eu aucun
rôle finalement dans ce processus de
paix qui a essayé d'être engagé avec les
talibans mais c'est justement vous le
dit bien les européennes n'a eu aucun
rôle en fait on est passif on attend
d'avoir alors qu'on a quelque chose à
dire donc moi j'ai fait ça on a aidé on
à aider l'afghanistan on n'aide en a
beaucoup on a beaucoup un budget prévu
pour ça on a encore entendu la prison de
la commission dire qu'on allait
augmenter son budget c'est donc
aujourd'hui il faut évidemment se
concentrer sur les femmes et les filles
les gens qui défendent les droits
humains en afghanistan mais sans
légitimer les talibans sans renforcer
leur pouvoir et celle là là c'est
vraiment assez difficile à faire et on
aura besoin de réponses au cours des
semaines qui viennent c'est la façon
dont la commission va procéder pour
acheminer l'aide et sur la façon dont va
procéder pour se faire respecter et
faire respecter les droits humains et
aussi au niveau de l'immigration on va
évidemment devoir accueillir les gens il
faut aider les gens il faut les
accueillir mais il faut également
construire au niveau de la région on ne
peut pas dire que voilà tout ce qu'ils
doivent s'enfuit de l'afghanistan hop
ils vont venir en europe c'est toujours
la même philosophie ce n'est pas si
facile et ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
possible non plus on a la même situation
au sahel donc la france aura bientôt
peut-être un autre afghanistan dans ce
qui se passe au sahel dans la région
ouest africaine alors vous le disiez
avec les talibans l'une des liens d
inquiétude c'est la place des femmes
dans le pays leur condition s'améliorer
petit à petit mais elle restait quand
même très précaires et quelles sont vos
craintes est ce que vous pensez à un
retour de la charia on pense qu'on pense
au fait que quand j'ai les taliban
étaient au pouvoir à l'époque la burqa
était obligatoire par exemple est ce que
c'est c'est l'une de vos craintes oui
j'ai beaucoup de craintes mais aussi un
peu d'espoir un peu d'espoir parce que
venant moi même d'une culture très près
à patriarcale traits assez
traditionnel où il y avait quand même
l'influencent la religion islamique
aussi je crois que il y a un effet sur
les petites filles quand elles fois la
liberté la première fois que j'ai vu une
femme libre cela m'a fait quelque chose
et après on peut plus vous enlever ça de
la tête mais après il faut tout un
chemin pour arriver à conquérir cette
liberté donc les femmes afghanes ou
encore tout un chemin à parcourir et là
on les abandonne un peu dans leur élan
et ça c'est vraiment dommage c'est très
inquiétant les talibans promettent monts
et merveilles mais on sait très bien que
c'est des relations publiques et qui
n'ont pas du tout l'intention c'est
impossible leur idéologie est basé sur
la domination de la femme elle doit
rester au foyer et mettre au monde
surtout des garçons est elle-même en
soit elle n'est rien d'autre qu'un qu'un
utérus et et un buffet qui leur faire
manger c'est tout et donc aujourd'hui ça
ne va pas changer quel que soit ce
qu'ils disent il faut qu'on reste
vigilant mais qu on reste vigilant aussi
par rapport à l'islamisme sur l'a10
charisme islamique aussi en europe et
j'ai vu à la ville est ce que vous
pensez qu'il ya beaucoup de soutien à ce
qui se passe en afghanistan en europe il
n'y a je n'ai pas encore vu les gens qui
soutenaient vraiment ouvertement les
talibans mais nous étions au danemark
pour la conférence pour les droits de
l'homme et il y avait une collègue
député qui a pris un taxi et le
chauffeur du taxi était quelqu'un qui
lui disait à quel point les talibans
était formidable elle nous l'a raconté
on a eu un peu la chair de poule parce
que c'est quand même inquiétant mais
aujourd'hui c'est que les talibans
défendent cet islamisme radical il
existe également en europe et il ya des
gens qui le soutiennent mais quand on
voit les talibans qui font ce qu'ils
font tout le monde dit oui mais il faut
il faut arrêter ça c'est inacceptable
on voit une petite fille qui soutient à
l'aéroport en belgique on dit c'est
génial c'est le symbole de la liberté
très bien mais j'étais à souligner que
les gens qui sont en tout dit
enthousiaste et je suis d'accord avec
lui il faut être enthousiaste quand on
voit une petite fille sautier parce
qu'elle est libre ils doivent aussi les
autres jours défendre les petites filles
des quartiers ici qui elles souffrent au
quotidien sous le poids de l'islamisme
dans les quartiers mais alors là on dit
mais c'est leur culture laissez les
faire alors ça c'est dangereux il faut
il faut être cohérent quand l'état liste
quand des camps les taliban étaient au
pouvoir en afghanistan entre 96 et 2001
des femmes et exécuté sur la place
publique est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est malheureusement quelque chose qui
pourrait revenir malgré le fait qu'ils
disent qu'ils ont changé qu'ils sont
ouverts notamment à l'éducation par
exemple je ne peux pas aller dans
l'avenir mais si j'étais aussi si en
tant que femme je n'aimerais vraiment
pas être en afghanistan ça c'est très
évident si j'étais une personne
homosexuelle
je voudrais pas non plus être en
afghanistan si j'ai une petite fille qui
doit encore grandir dit je voudrais pas
non plus je crois qu'il n'y a rien dans
ce qu'ils promettent dans ce qu'ils sont
dans ce qui me ils ont démontré jusque
là qui permet d'imaginer que ce sera le
paradis pour les femmes en tout cas pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le cas donc je
crois qu'il faut qu'on soit vigilant et
qu'on ne faut pas être naïf si on
imagine on laisse les talibans nous
bercer avec leurs belles chansons en
disant qu'ils vont donner la liberté aux
femmes
ça va mal se passer je crois qu'il faut
rester vigilant resté ferme tout en
gardant un lien avec la société civile
et les activistes qui défendent les
droits des femmes c'est important avec
cette situation en afghanistan vous le
disiez se pose la question des réfugiés
quelle est la place de l'europe dans
l'extradition de ces réfugiés est ce
qu'il aurait fallu s'y prendre plus en
amont pour évacuer des gens oui est ce
que il n'est pas trop tard finalement et
est-ce qu'il aurait pas fallu une
réponse à l'échelle européenne je pense
qu'il est totale pour beaucoup de choses
et pas seulement pour ceux ci je crois
que il fallait agir en amont passe passe
pas seulement quand le président byden a
commencé à dire qu'il fallait qu'il
allait quitter l'afghanistan il a il a
évoqué les trois cent mille soldats
formés que face à 75000
sondant talibans mais
c'était c'est évident c'était évident
que ça allait mal se passer et que
kaboul allait tomber et donc on a été ta
nourriture on aurait dû et c'est
toujours comme ça on attend toujours le
dernier moment et même là il y c'est un
pensez qu'à nous fut la réaction et
vouloir effectuer les européens les
américains simplement nous en priorité
au dernier moment et on s'est dit on
évacuera ce qui reste dans ce qui reste
comme place on aurait dû évacuer les
gens beaucoup plus tôt et des personnes
qui habitent ici n'aurait pas dû aller
en vacances en afghanistan malgré les
conseils du ministère des affaires
étrangères donc il fallait respecter
cela je crois que quand ben laden est
venu tout le monde a été ébloui par son
discours à l'otan par tous les jolis
mots et par le fait qu'il n'est patron
mais en réalité on n'a pas vu notre
propre rôle et la réaction que l'union
européenne devait avoir par rapport à ça
et je trouve que c'est c'est vraiment
moi j'ai honte quand je vois comment
nous avons réagi de manière passive et
on est toujours en train de courir
derrière les faits c'est une politique
dure et tard et c'est dommage et les
talibans vois ça aujourd'hui ils ne vont
pas vous avez demandé s'il existait une
femme en lui blick moi je pense qu'ils
sont à une autre étape où ils vont aller
de manière beaucoup plus subtil que cela
donc aujourd'hui en privant de légende
éducation par exemple ça c'est une façon
d'exécuter une femme parce qu'on lui
enlève tous les moyens on allait tous en
france voilà tout son potentiel et elle
a goûté à ce que c'est que cette liberté
là et elle la veut plus qu'avant et donc
il faut qu'on nourrissent un peu ce
pouvoir là je crois que c'est c'est un
écrivain français qui avait dit que pour
pour construire un bateau il faut pas
rassemblé ses hommes et ses femmes et
leur donner des matériels de donner des
ordres il faut leur donner le désir
profond de la mer et j'espère que le
désir la liberté est là et que la graine
s est mis et qu'elle va continuer à
pousser nous on devra condé va aider à
la rose est alors un autre problème qui
se pose c'est que la turquie est à la
frontière de tous et de tous ces
conflits la turquie accueille déjà trois
millions et demi de réfugiés syriens la
turquie est en train de construire un
mur à sa frontière avec l'iran pour
empêcher l'afflux de migrants afghans
ankara se trouve une nouvelle fois la
garde frontières de l'europe comment
est-ce que l'union européenne va encore
gérer une nouvelle crise va s'ouvrir à
la turquie c'est encore algérien gérer
la conséquences de l'inaction alors que
si on avait agi en amour on ne serait
pas dans cette situation et ça ne
concerne pas que la tradition c'est
aussi ce qui se passe hier encore il ya
eu un bateau qui a dû être secourues au
large de lampedusa avec plus de 700
réfugiés à bord migrants à bord et donc
on assiste à une répétition des choses
et la turquie va continuer à monnayer sa
position et cette absence de politique
migratoire et l'union européenne va
continuer à se laisser avoir et il n'ya
pas que la turquie aujourd'hui on doit
également faire face à l'attitude de la
chine et du pakistan qui joue double jeu
avec avec les talibans donc on risque de
se retrouver dans une situation où on
n'a rien à dire on va simplement subir
et courir après les faits et gérer des
conséquences et subir d'autres chantage
de la part d'air dogan ou de houe de son
remplaçant ou alors on va se faire avoir
quand il y aura quelqu'un d'autre qui
remplacera erdogan qui sera peut-être
moins brutale apparemment on va faire
comme on a fait avec bud et trompe en
disant oh mais il est tout gentil le
président américain moi je dis pas qu'il
est méchant mais il défend son pays il
défend son pays et c'est le rôle c'est
le rôle des dirigeants politiques ce que
nous devons faire c'est défendre l'euro
merci beaucoup à saissac encore d'avoir
été avec nous dans un europe /
sensations je le rappelle vous êtes vice
présidente du groupe des conservateurs
et réformistes européens et puis vous
êtes membre de la commission des
libertés civiles de la justice et des
affaires intérieures et membre de la
sous-commission des droits de l'homme
zone europe expression d'ici et
d'ailleurs
alors on arrive au terme de cette
émission et on en vient à notre rubrique
consacrée aux expressions populaires
l'expression pour dire jamais les
néerlandais 10 quand les veaux danseront
sur la glace est ce qu'il ya une
équivalence en belgique pour dire jamais
dire jamais on dit quand les poules
auront des dents oui oui tout à fait au
burkina faso aussi bouger sinon on dit
quand les poules auront des dents mais
je ne connais pas l'expression flamande
pour dire jamais sans doute parce que je
ne le dirais armand ou que je le dis
presque pas je crois aux possibilités
d'avancer donc je connais plutôt des
expressions très optimiste très bien
merci beaucoup alors que dit-on ailleurs
regardez les roumains 10 quand le cochon
volera en italie on dit wall yasi niveau
les rats non cela signifie quand les
ânes voleront aux pays bas ont dit qu'on
allait vous danseront sur la glace
au rendez vous europe s'est terminée
merci aux équipes techniques du
parlement européen de bruxelles vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations mais
également sur tv 78 rendez vous la
semaine prochaine très bonne soirée
soon robe sûr sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france